welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka lord spoil real
in this video we're breaking down the
latest century of his dark materials
and giving you some terrible puns to go
along with it
now have taken a two-week hiatus of
posting this after the first episode
breakdown
and that's purely because of the release
schedule of the show
it actually drops one week in advance in
england but as with most of my
subscribers being american
i thought i'd hold off just so you guys
have had some time to watch it
and also because because the first video
the terrible view wise anyway
episode 2 starts very strangely and i
was actually a bit disappointed that
they completely dropped the cliffhanger
from last time if you cast your mind
back you'll remember that we ended the
prior entry with will being stalked by a
specter
and just as it was about to attack the
episode cut to black
that plot point doesn't appear again and
the episode picks up the next morning
with
everything all fine and dandy pan is in
the form of a red panda
and i kind of hope that he takes on this
shape more often as he's called pan
and he's well a panda never mind anyway
he's not the only one who's transformed
either and lyra is trying on different
clothes in order to blend in
this entry centers around lyra and pan
going to wells oxford for the first time
and almost immediately upon entering it
trouble starts to find them
after lyra is knocked down by a car we
see as lord boreal watches them
and slowly he puts into place his plans
to get the golden compass
one of the strange things about the
episode is that boreal and lyra
actually come face to face at one point
and she doesn't recognize him at all
you may remember that he was at mrs
coulter's party in the first season
but for some reason she doesn't quite
remember who he is
which allows him to sink his claws into
her slightly now boreal is actually a
play on the word aurora borealis
which the story of course centers around
in addition to this
in the source material boreal goes by
the name
sir charles lashram latron backwards is
mortal
so you very much get this aesthetic of
his pseudonyms being a play on words
boreal has been tasked with tracking
down john parry
who as we know is going to be played by
andrew scott
now they have changed his character
slightly for the series
as in the book boreal was an old man who
used his kindly and gentle appearance to
manipulate lara in several ways
other than the cars there are also a lot
of similarities of oxford to lyras
however one bigger mission is jordan's
college
which is currently just a construction
site in world's reality
lyra is pretty disappointed by this but
i do love that she bumps into several
people and has to dash out of the way of
bikes
in her world airships and boats are sort
of the main methods of transportation
and though there are cars they aren't
used as regularly it is a nice little
detail that shows the creative team were
paying attention to how the little
aspects would change
and i really appreciated it just seeing
lyra fall over all the time
anyway they compare will's phone to the
compass and after he receives a lot of
notifications from his mum
the pair split up they agree to meet at
the botanical gardens
which is a location that exists in both
will and lyra's oxford
elsewhere the magisterium are mourning
the death of their cardinal
and the senate from star wars is
assembled to decide what to do next
father mcphail has now taken over the
reigns of the group
and this is of course a power play by
mrs coulter in order to gain control
over them
lyra heads into a museum and it's at
this point that she asks for help
finding a scholar that will tell her
about
dust not only does the compass tell her
to look for the door with a mountain on
it
it also tells her to look for the
scholar and to help will find his father
now as we know
will and lyra's fate are very heavily
linked together
and both are pretty much the opposites
of one another in their respective
worlds
opposites same characters you know what
i mean anyway the point is
that boreal here makes his play but
rather than attacking lyra and taking
the compass for himself
he decides to do a different strategy
this involves gaining her trust
in the hopes that she will drop her god
now i always thought that this moment
held a lot of biblical similarities
and as we know boreal's demon is the
snake
the snake was very prominent in the
garden of eden and even tempted eve with
the idea of knowledge
lyra and will could somewhat be viewed
as almost adam and eve like figures
and from their respective worlds they've
both sort of been abandoned by their
fathers
and cast into a paradise which i think
the island represents
boreal is trying to gain knowledge as
well as getting eve or rather lyra on
his side
and thus he's doing the long game which
involves making her trust him
i don't know if i'm reading into that
but whenever i see a snake
an object that can grant knowledge along
with a male and female character
i think it's done on purpose to
reference the good book
boreal lets her leave and will goes to
his mother to let her know that he's
okay
cut to the witches and we see seraphina
confronting ruta
over her attack last week this ambush
has really rocked the status of things
and it could easily send them into an
all-out war that could completely ravage
the planet
as we know the cardinal is dead and ruta
wants to capitalize on this by uniting
the nine clans in order to take the
magisterium whilst they still can
however seraphina is sure that the
prophecy which centers around lyra
is the right action to take and she's
worried that if they can't get to her in
time
at all will be lost now speaking of lyra
she arrives at the dark matters research
unit in the college
to find mary malone bird watching malone
becomes an incredibly important
character in the work
and after discussing dark matter and
dust mary reveals some significant
things
namely that dark matter and dust have a
conscious to them
now as we discussed in our last
breakdown different things in different
realities have different words assigned
to them
for example demon in our world means
something completely different in lyra's
and we discover that both dark matter
and dust are one in the same
now the magisterium makes some bold
moves and at their headquarters we watch
as kolter and boreal meet
it's a very tense conversation with both
subtly suggesting that they know secrets
about the other boreal says that he's
been visiting another world
and cult is is that her daughter lyra is
missing boreal of course knows where she
is
and colter is desperate to find this out
now before things really heat up
dr martin is brought before the
magisterium and though he's there to try
and broke a piece
macphail doesn't buy it ruta has really
caused a lot of
issues and though this would normally
lead to things settling down
it actually causes more problems martin
is sentenced to eight years hard labor
and we also get a hint at towards what
could be going on with coulter
this is because we learn of a region in
the north in which demons cannot go
in order to become a witch a girl must
venture into there without her demon
and it allows for them to be separated
from the soul without killing either
as we know from season one calder can
separate from her demon
and i think the focus on her as this is
being discussed is definitely meant to
hint to us that she was part of a ritual
now elsewhere we watch his will learns
through his father's will
pun intended who his grandparents are
crap pun though wasn't it
but they're not like your grandparents
or mine
where they just want to give you food
and money all the time are actually a
bunch of snitches
and thus he leaves to find lyra now lyra
and malone
really get into the lore of dust and how
it can only be measured upon being
viewed
however this is difficult because the
particles don't reflect light
and thus mary has had to build a
computer to help her examine the matter
this computer in many ways is very
similar to the compass
in that it can answer specific questions
if one mind is put into a certain state
when connected to it with the compass
one must
sort of exist in between states whereas
with the computer
you can actually just hook yourself up
to it thus lyra journeys to the computer
cave with malone
and she's jacked into it is that the
correct phrasing i don't know but it
sounds cool anyway
what matters here is the multiple
symbols from the compass
that are brought to the machine now
shout outs to screen rant for breaking
these all down
and the first letters that we get are
the alpha and omega symbols
from the greek alphabet these are
actually laid over the top of one
another
and they carry a lot of meanings
according to random house who published
the book
the alpha and omega mean finality and
inevitability
which could hint towards the prophecy
that involves lyra
the symbols also appeared in the book of
revelations as a title for god
so it's very much tied in with the
ending of things and great power
next is another symbol of power which is
the sun
on the compass this means day however it
also represents
truth it could hint that the truth will
come to light
down the line and i swear that's not a
pun next is the owl
which means the opposite to the sun and
rather than day
it means night however it also brings
with it the idea of winter and fear
as well as a hunter lyra of course has
lord boreal after her
and it could tease the trials that are
coming to her down the line
owls also typically represent wisdom so
this could tie in with malone who's
going to be guiding the character
there's also the ai ching or iching is
it or
anyway it's the book of changes which is
a historical chinese text that's used to
grant wisdom
this book actually pops up later in the
story after malone manages to get it
and sorry if that's ruined everything
for you i hope not though
now the knife also appears and this is
the subtle knife which is a big mcguffin
in the season
i got into trouble on the last video for
spoiling what it does so i won't do that
here
but if you want to know then definitely
go check out the previous entry that we
did it was a brilliant breakdown
i must say myself lastly is the
hourglass which no prize is for guessing
represents time
and the appearance of this reminds lyra
that she has to meet wills specifically
at 5pm
and the two rendezvous at the gardens
now the bench itself
is a big big big easter egg
i'm not going to ruin its significance
just yet but it's actually tied heavily
into the storyline
and in real life there's actually a
statue of demons placed beside it
having the pan meteor is very important
and this fourth wall breaking moment i
think will make a lot of fans of the
source material
very very happy will and lyra really
share a touching moment at this point
and using the elithiometer she confirms
that his mother is okay
it also tells the pair that they need to
find will's father however because of
the betrayal carried out by his
grandparents
will doesn't know who to trust lyra of
course relates to this
after being betrayed by both her father
and mother and really start to see the
character's similarities line up
i think this bench will be back before
you know it and once lockdown ends in
the uk
i'm gonna go there and get a selfie
probably not though anyway back at the
magisterium
culture convinces macphail to launch
airships on the witches
which completely bombard them this is
obviously gonna further the war between
the two sides
and macphail sees it as a necessary sin
he actually punishes himself in private
for it
and holds his hand over a candle which
burns the flesh
on it elsewhere coulter discovers from
thorold that lyra has traveled to
another world
and she'll obviously be heading to the
city of gaza in order to try and track
her down
you also see as the attack commences on
the witches and the magisterium carry
out their burning ritual
whilst the landscape of the witches does
too this
is a declaration of war and i was
shocked at how impactful this final
scene was
something about the intercutting of the
witch's home burning whilst mcphail
stands in front of a flame
was really emotional i thought and
obviously going forward
it's gonna be all-out war between the
pair mcphail has finally gained the
power he's long sought after
but colter states that it's actually a
curse that he's been given
and that he's merely a fly in her web
she divulges the multiverse
and then says she's going on her mission
to find lara she calls macphail hugh
as a way to show that she doesn't
respect him at all and the episode ends
with her leaving
with one of the best struts i've ever
seen and that concludes the entry and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and what you want to see in the
show going forward
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and check out our recap of the first
entry in case you missed it
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of november so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat just on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you